SCP Foundation agents stationed at Area 37
had intercepted chatter from a normally closed
communication system in a nearby city.
To anyone else, the calls that the Foundation
were eavesdropping would seem innocent - even
boring, but the Foundation immediately recognized
the coded language being used.
They were listening to communications between
underground cells of The Serpent’s Hand
- a dangerous paramilitary organization that
stands in opposition to everything the Foundation
is trying to do.
Once deciphered, the Serpent’s Hand messages
revealed plans for killing Foundation personnel,
breaking into containment sites, and releasing
anomalous creatures and objects into the world
- pretty standard stuff for the Foundation’s
least-favorite, anomaly-loving insurgents.
But they kept using one code that even the
Foundation didn’t have any intel on - they
kept asking about the condition of The Sisters.
Fate has a funny way of sneaking up on you
though, and in time, they would know more
about the powerful, sadistic, reality-warping
beings known as The Sisters than they could
have possibly imagined.
But what they would eventually learn was not
the kind of data that anyone would ever want
to have.
After intercepting clear lines of communication
from a local Serpent’s Hand cell, triangulating
the location of their compound was child’s
play, and Mobile Task Forces were dispatched
from Area 37 with orders to neutralize the
potential threat before they could mount an
attack on a facility.
Just when the Serpent’s Hands least expected
it, they had heavily-armed Foundation soldiers
kicking down their doors, crashing through
windows, and rappelling down from the ceiling.
As expected, the Serpent’s Hand put up a
fight, but thanks to their superior training
and the element of surprise, the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces came out on top.
They were able to capture fifteen surviving
members of the group for interrogation, as
well as a collection of anomalous objects
being stored by the group.
Among them were a small wooden loom, an enamel
needle, and a glass eye.
When the task force obtained these seemingly
mundane items, a haunted-looking Serpent’s
Hand began laughing wildly.
He kept repeating, “You have no idea what
you’re getting yourselves into...”
Nobody knew just how right this man was.
Not yet, anyway.
Congratulating themselves on a job well done,
the Mobile Task Forces hauled their captives
and the new anomalous items back to Area 37
- a heavily isolated Foundation site that
specializes in the early containment of anomalous
objects for initial observation and study.
The objects hadn’t displayed any anomalous
properties in transit - maybe the Serpent’s
Hand was lying and these weren’t dangerous
items at all, or it was actually just a pile
of junk.
Either way, they were sent to a Foundation
researcher on site to conduct preliminary
tests.
The loom, the needle, and the glass eye were
laid out across the table for observation,
when suddenly, the attending researcher felt
a dark presence looming behind him.
He turned, with sweat beading on his brow,
and saw three humanoid, translucent figures
floating in the air behind him.
They would soon become known as SCP - 1765
One, Two, and Three.
The researcher could feel the power emanating
from these silhouettes - reality seemed to
bend and shimmer around them, the way heat
distorts the air into a mirage.
He could tell right away that they were powerful
reality-warpers.
Even in their brief time communicating with
the researcher, One, Two, and Three displayed
both intelligence and unique personalities.
One was clearly the ringleader - displaying
an articulate command of language.
Two displayed a more mischievous side, speaking
with a cockney accent and had a tendency towards
creepy giggling.
Three was the least communicative of them
all - preferring to speak in short, simple
sentences, often consisting of just single
words.
Though of course, actions speak far louder
than words - and it didn’t take long for
the Sisters to define themselves with their
actions.
One told the scared and confused researcher
that they’d been observing the SCP Foundation
for quite some time, and that they deeply
admired the Foundation’s adherence to the
scientific method.
Of course, the researcher wasn’t so much
“flattered” by the Sister’s statement
as they were “afraid for their life.”
They tried to call security for backup, but
found that their tongue was withering and
turning into a shrivelled, blackened husk
in their mouth.
The Sisters didn’t like to be interrupted.
As the tongueless researcher slowly collapsed
in front of them, the Sisters explained the
purpose of their visit - They wished to assist
the Foundation in their quest for knowledge,
and, as such, they would conduct a number
of experiments on their behalf.
They would then happily share the resulting
data with the Foundation to compare notes.
One expressed optimism, saying that she believed
they were about to embark on a beautiful scientific
relationship.
The reality couldn’t be further from the
truth.
The Sisters began their work, moving rapidly
around the facility, bending and twisting
reality wherever they went.
They circled Area 37, marking it as separate
from the rest of the world it inhabited.
Area 37 no longer belonged to planet earth
- it belonged to the Sisters.
It was their private experimentation lab,
filled with live and unwilling guinea pigs.
The Foundation attempted to retake the facility
by force, sending Mobile Task Force Iota-6,
also known as the Canvas Cats, into the belly
of the beast, but they never returned.
In addition to changing the fabric of reality
itself, they also altered the physical structure
of Area 37 to better serve their experimental
designs.
It was divided into four sections, marked
A, B, C, and D, each with its own unique purpose.
Section A - which had formerly been Area 37’s
storekeeping, mess hall, and dormitories - had
been the least affected by the Sisters’
attacks on reality.
The biggest alterations were the appearance
of two large, metal vats situated in the east
corner of the mess hall, a monitoring station
connected to other sections of Area 37 that
replaced the storekeeping zones, and an imposing
marble sign hanging above the dormitories
that reads “CONTROL GROUP.”
A quick refresher from science class, the
control group in an experiment is the group
that isn’t subjected to the experimental
effect the others are, so they can be used
as a benchmark to measure against.
The same was true here - the prisoners in
the control group were the safest of all,
but they were forced to do something almost
as bad, they had to watch the horrors playing
out across the rest of the facility.
One of the Sisters would occasionally return
to this section to oversee the feeding of
the control subjects, and to encourage them
to take part in the observation of their unlucky
peers.
Section B - which had formerly been Area 37’s
outer grounds and sports facilities - had
been transformed into the center of a localized
spatial-temporal abnormality.
In layman’s terms, this meant that its size,
climate, atmospheric composition, pressure,
and temporal flow were all subject to constant
changes based on the whims of Sister Number
One - who oversaw all the experiments performed
in Section B.
For those unfortunate enough to be trapped
in Section B, SCP-1765-1 was their god.
But she didn’t subject them to her whims
randomly.
No, in her own words, the purpose of Section
B was to delve into the effects of repetitive
action performed under unusual conditions
on the human psyche.
For example, one experiment was set up to
test the physical and mental fortitude of
a Researcher, a Field Agent, and a sanitation
worker.
The trio were confined in a sports center
and ordered to measure the length of every
single pipe and the angle at which each connected
to others with nothing more than a wrench,
a ruler, a brown paper pad and a ballpoint
pen.
The task was an arduous one taking over ten
hours.
And as soon as the subjects were done, One
restructured the sports center and ordered
them to perform the task again.
The same happened another 459 times before
One finally concluded the experiment, leaving
the subjects with broken bodies and minds
in the aftermath.
Section C - which had previously been the
facility’s main office block - exhibited
a similar level of anomalous activity to Section
B, except that it was the domain of the more
sadistic and mischievous Sister Number Two.
Her main area of scientific interest was studying
group dynamics and interpersonal relationships
during extreme conditions - very extreme conditions.
For one experiment, the office block had been
transformed into a kind of football stadium,
with the goal posts removed and replaced by
concrete bunkers.
The two teams were the captured Serpent Hand
members, and the members of MTF Iota-6, fresh
off their attempt to retake the site.
The two groups were forced into a deadly game
with incomprehensible rules - including rising
platforms and hooded figures throwing fiery
projectiles into the crowd, trying to incinerate
the players.
But victory didn’t lead to safety, as the
winners of the game were crushed to death
with giant metal hammers, just for the fun
of it.
Two didn’t even try to pretend that this
act had a valid scientific justification.
Section D - which had once been the facility’s
high-risk containment area - was now the strangest
and most mysterious section of all.
Under the charge of the equally peculiar and
enigmatic Sister Number Three, this area appeared
physically unchanged from its state prior
to the arrival of the Sisters.
Temporally, however, Section D was the most
warped of them all.
It existed in a kind of temporal bubble, outside
of the rest of our reality’s timeline, giving
Three a frightening amount of control over
all that went on in her domain outside of
time.
There she was performing the most strange
and incomprehensible experiment of all.
The subject was the former Site Director of
Area 37.
He was brought to a table, and asked to choose
between two different flavors of ice cream
that were presented to him.
Sounds simple enough, so then why is this
the worst of them all?
Because the Site Director is caught in a time
loop.
He’s been choosing between various flavors
of ice cream for over ten thousand hours,
and he doesn’t even seem to know.
Three’s only comment on the matter?
“Delicious.”
All attempts to liberate the unfortunate inhabitants
of Area 37 have failed miserably.
The Sisters don’t appear to operate on any
form of logic or empathy, and thus, cannot
be reasoned with.
With talks having failed and Mobile Task Force
Iota-6’s attempt to retake the site ending
in disaster, the only solution left was to
create a guarded perimeter around the area,
using technology like the Scranton Reality
Anchor to fight back against any potential
escape by the Sisters.
The Sisters are potentially so dangerous that
if they ever truly set their minds to leaving,
it’s considered acceptable to detonate the
facility’s on-site nuclear warhead in hopes
of finally putting a stop to them.
In the meantime, the Foundation has built
giant external servers for processing the
vast quantities of research data the Sisters
are constantly sending from their horrifying
experiments.
Sadly for the inhabitants of Area 37, their
grim fate continues to this day.
The experiments never stop, and the subjects
of said experiments seem to be condemned to
the eternal torment of SCP - 1765.
In a way, their unwilling sacrifice protects
us all - because if ever the Sisters were
interested in performing experiments on a
larger sample size…
Well, all we can do is hope we end up in the
control group.
Now go check out “SCP - 1730 - What happened
to Site-13?” and “SCP - 1730 - Epic Final
Battle at Site-13” for more about the strangest
SCP sites around the world.